it was always you know we always have
this question Oh what would it be like
if we made an ex-con where you're
playing as the aliens no I don't think
that would work very well because your
emotional connection to like you know
Glee Corbin I mean you just don't feel
as strongly right you can't look at them
and be like corpse all right right got
some points all right yeah but you know
you're just that resonance isn't there
but we're like well how can we get that
sort of sense hello commander and
welcome to the final part of our
three-part series on X cough today we
look to the future to 2016 on XCOM to
see we change the color of the light
that's how you know we're talking about
the new video game in yesterday's video
we talked to Jake Solomon about the
challenge of bringing XCOM back how him
and his teammate Firaxis had to make
difficult decisions about what to cut
and what to keep in today's video we
talked to Jake about his plans for the
sequel and first things first Jake wants
to take the controlled experience of
2012's XCOM and make it a lot less
predictable the strategy layer on XCOM
enemy Unknown is a little more linear
it was the case of we have to be real
careful like we can't take our hands off
the reins let's control the experience
we want it to be this hard this are this
hard this hard we need to make sure the
players advancing at this rate this
right when you played it multiple times
you kind of saw okay like this is these
are the beats this is how it works and
then we realized after we released enemy
unknown okay well people are okay with
that and we can actually take our hands
off the reins and say it's more fun to
be a little more unpredictable and have
these experiences where game that gave
me like well that's crazy this time was
really hard beginning and then I got a
leg up or the next time it they got
super difficult because they did all
these things at the end of the game so
the original sequel to XCOM teraphim the
deep was essentially a reskin of the
first game but it was the gallop
brothers sequel apocalypse that really
tried to move the needle interestingly
one of my memories of that game is the
unpredictable strategy layer if you play
badly in early levels of Cataclysm the
aliens aggression would actually
decrease but if you were successful and
played really well in those early
missions
they'd more quickly attack your home
base
so what Jake is talking about breaking
at the strategy layer so it's as
unpredictable as the turn-based parts of
the game makes me feel excited for a
similar experience yeah and it's nice to
know that there's this sort of shared
knowledge out there and but they're the
ones that kind of you know educated us
I'm like we're fine you should you know
you know feel free to give us more
because we're fine you know and that was
nice
and as you can see what they what they
played what they liked and then they're
like yeah give us more give us more
unpredictability as a designer you look
great that's awesome fear axis is no
stranger to sequels this is a company
well aware of the challenges of
releasing iterative games so when it
came to Jake and the XCOM team to make
their first sequel to XCOM they looked
across the hall you know we're in the
same studio as Civ right and Civ yes and
he the sim is huge it's it's the biggest
game that nobody views is like the
biggest game in the industry they're
huge I mean such nice guys and girls
that work on Civ very nice you know
unassuming and they just have this
monster hit that they're making over
there very playable like if you go on
Steam there's still 30 40 thousand
people concurrently playing civ 5 which
came up forever ago they do that so well
that's what we wanted to reach is we
have a very playable game a lot of
people still play it but we were like ok
we also want to make a game that when
players buy it you know they know like
ok I'm spending like pennies per hour
for like gameplay I mean I was sort of
like replayable replayable replayable
like the kind of games we make yet you
have to be good to your audience because
they're your core have to have this sort
of back and forth loyalty and for us
that means I let's make a game that when
we give it to them and they pay us their
hard earned money they feel great about
it and that meant a lot of modding
support making the game much more
unpredictable so it's fun every time you
play procedural levels all that stuff
that sort of fuels allowing players to
play a lot we've just done so many
things a lot of is adding unpredictable
stuff to the game so you know you can
build an advanced grenade but you don't
know what kind you're going to get
that's the kind of thing that just it
surprises you and makes you play
different every time you can create all
in customize all these characters that
you're scientists and engineers they
could be soldiers they can be bad guys
and then you have them in this pool and
those characters now will live in every
single player game you play they can
show up as recruits and if there are
characters you love in your current game
you can just Oh say save that to the
character pool and now they'll be there
forever and they'll show back up and so
we're like okay we have to make sure
maps are new every time that was a huge
technical challenge but that was the
number one thing people wanted more mods
support for the game that allows people
to sort of make new experiences and
things like that those are all things
that are driven basically by our fans
saying it is these are things you'd like
the other major change in ex-con to is a
fundamental shift in power between the
antagonist and the protagonist an ex-con
to the aliens of one they've
successfully invaded earth an ex-con is
working as a guerrilla resistance for us
to try and gain back the planet flying
around in their portable base to look
into rumors and make contact with new
regions
you know XCOM enemy Unknown it was
stressful because you started with the
whole world you know and then you
started just losing one by one like I
never ever said when I told him about
that he was kind of like hmm he's like
so you're playing not to lose and I'm
like yeah but it's more fun than that
but we said alright well what if we
change the roles to where the aliens
rule earth and an X comes job is to sort
of attack quickly and build up these
like take the countries away from the
aliens basically and so you're going
around and you're gathering regions that
are under alien control and you sort of
reversing the whole trend of X column
you're reversing in X country one of the
many pleasures of playing the first game
was finding your areas to fight in a new
alien types to fight against so as
expected XCOM 2 is introducing a host of
new environments and alien types but
Jake and the team aren't spilling the
beans on all of them just yet lots of
new places where the player can play
lots of new map types you know because
everything from these beautiful cities
to then you go out to the wilderness
there's just remnants of old
civilization aliens we've almost doubled
the number of Haven so there's just tons
and tons of humans one of the aliens
were just starting to talk about this is
a favorite of mine is the faceless and
they're great because they're actual
civilians and so they're walking around
the city maps or in like you you're
going to save some money you're going to
save civilians on a mission or you're
just you're in concealment here and the
answer over there and there's civilians
talking over here but any one of those
can be a faceless well so what's the
faceless appear then they basically like
if you get close to them or if they just
see you you know the civilian may walk a
little closer you know and then the next
term they just erupt into this huge like
huge just trippy looking mess of an
alien and so they're it's yeah it's
great we have like the Advent which is
like the sort of soldiers that work as
the foot soldiers for the healing so
that's like a sort of World Police Force
I'm excited for XCOM - I like the idea
of a less predictable and forgiving
strategy layer I look forward to seeing
how the new aliens might change the
boots on the ground action and honestly
the idea of flying around the world and
making peace with all the countries who
decided to cut funding with me back in
2012 sounds pretty great - but that's
not really why I feel optimistic about
XCOM the real reason is because of Jake
and the team of men and women working at
four axes in 2012 they managed the
impossible for Jake XCOM isn't just a
game it's his life's work a series which
inspired him to be a programmer which
landed him his dream job and one he now
holds ultimate responsibility for the
last person is going to allow ex-con to
have a by-the-numbers sequel is Jake
Salomon I have got a job that I I wake
up and I still don't believe it I mean
I'm in my life for me I'm in my lifetime
job like I'm
there's no interest in me to do
something else like I wake up I'm like
great I got to go make X come and so
that's how I always feel and so I just
got very lucky to get this job and have
this opportunity and yeah it feels
awesome
you